hey guys it is may the 4th aka star wars
day and I actually have some Star Wars
news for you so let's get right to that
Electronic Arts exact Patrick soderlund
revealed that the publisher is working
with titanfall dev respawn entertainment
to create a new star wars game although
there will also be putting time into
titanfall to respawn is set to create a
quote all new third-person
action-adventure game set in the Star
Wars universe EA own studios capital
gains Visceral Games dice Bioware and
motive are also all working on Star Wars
projects so EA really does hope you like
Star Wars development on respawns
upcoming game is being led by god of war
3 director stink as Nelson who's called
the job the chance of a lifetime heey
published a blog where he said he's been
playing Star Wars games his whole life
and they are serious about paying
respect to the legacy of the series at
all times EA have already revealed
multiple battlefront sequels are in the
works while motive are creating their
star wars game under the guidance of
uncharted director Amy Hennig and
Assassin's Creed producer Jade Raymond
and visceral games is rumored to be
making an open world star wars type
Bethesda has announced that fallout 4
spa Harbor DLC will be arriving on May
nineteen on pc ps4 and xbox one the
expansion synopsis reads a new case from
Valentine's detective agency elites you
want to search for a young woman and a
secret colony of since travel off the
coast of Maine to the mysterious island
of Faja where higher levels of radiation
have created a more feral world navigate
through the growing conflict between the
synths a children of Adam and the local
townspeople the DLC features a bunch of
new quests settlements and more powerful
creatures as well as better gear to take
them on with it sells for 25 bucks and
is also included with the fifty-dollar
fallout 4 DLC pass there's also a brand
new trailer for the expansion which you
can check out on gamespot finally some
call of duty news the first tip it being
that two more call of duty 4 remaster
maps have
feels modern warfare remastered will
include 10 multiplayer maps from the
2007 original we know for sure crash
back lot and crossfire will be bring
appearing but oniy report from Forbes
have said that bog and overgrown will
also be part of the package Activision
has said all 10 maps are fan favorites
so be sure to keep an eye out for the
announcement of the remaining five
another card news infinite warfare will
not feature the campaign co-op that was
in court duty black ops 3 Activision
confirms that co-op will be limited to
the game zombie mode which is going to
feature a new storyline and unique
mechanics infinite warfare will put you
in the shoes of Captain raised a tier 1
spec ups pilot that Helms one of Earth's
last remaining warships the shooter will
factor in both air and space combat
significantly let me know down in that
comment section which maps you want to
see up here in modern warfare remastered
you can enter gamespot we've got news on
just one or two and uncharted 4
multiplied that's everything I've got
for you today enjoy having a star wars
marathon tonight or whatever it is you
decide to get up to and I will see you
again tomorrow